[Musique]
salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique et aujourd'hui je
vous propose de découvrir l'histoire
d'un courant politique américain sujet
de nombreux fantasmes le
néoconservatisme ce courant a une
particularité il est né au sein de la
gauche pour défendre une certaine vision
de la gauche et s'est décalé vers la
droite au point de finir dans le camp
républicain
et si cette histoire permet de
comprendre l'évolution du champ
politique américain elle permet aussi de
comprendre les dynamiques en cours au
sein de la gauche française
chez nous la gauche se déchirent depuis
plusieurs années sur les questions liées
à l'immigration et à la laïcité mais
aussi aux théories postmoderne et il se
trouve que nombre de mécanismes et de
querelles idéologiques liée à
l'apparition du néoconservatisme aux
états unis se retrouvent dans les débats
français
c'est pourquoi dans une prochaine vidéo
à partir de cette histoire américaine
je vous proposerai une grille
d'interprétation pour comprendre ce qui
se passe actuellement au sein de la
gauche française également une petite
remarque avant de commencer notre
histoire celle ci couvre trois décennies
et impliquent plusieurs dizaines de
politiciens et d'intellectuels aussi
pour ne pas vous saturez inutilement de
noms je me concentrerai que sur les
figures majeures
maintenant que c'est dit passons à notre
histoire symboliquement pour bien
marquer l'origine de gauche du
néoconservatisme ont fait
traditionnellement commencer la
préhistoire du courant dans les années
30 et 40 au city collège de new york
une sorte d'université publique gratuite
de seconde zone mais qui permet aux
familles pauvres et souvent d'origine
immigrée d'envoyer leurs enfants dans le
supérieur
car c'est une particularité sociologique
des premiers néoconservateurs ce ne sont
pas des wasps des white anglo saxon
protestant des descendants des premiers
colons anglais mais des immigrés récents
issus de milieux modestes le plus
souvent juif ou catholique new yorkais
parmi les étudiants du city collège dont
on reparlera dans notre récit on peut
citer irving kristol daniel bell nate
anglaise heures tous issus de familles
juives mais aussi daniel patrick monahan
venant lui d'une famille catholique
irlandaise à cette époque les futurs néo
conservateurs sont étudiants
ils sont à gauche et même certains très
à gauche la plupart ayant fréquenté un
cercle trotskiste établi au city collège
donc communiste anti stalinien et
critique de l'urss
bien sûr tous les néo conservateurs
n'ont pas été trotskiste et n'ont pas
fréquenté cette université par exemple
norman podhoretz qui sera pourtant une
fille
or majeur du mouvement suite à ces
années d'études au cours des années 50
et début des années 60 ce qui était
trotskiste ce sont des radis kenji eno
futur néo conservateurs sont devenus des
notables de gauche certains sont
journalistes comme podhoretz qui dirige
la revue commentary d'autres sont
universitaires comme bell christoph
glaser et d'autres ont intégré des
cabinets ministériels comme guinéenne
ils ont pris part aux combats de
l'époque comme la lutte pour les droits
civiques et ont passé une partie des
années 50 à lutter contre l' influence
communiste aux côtés des libéraux de
guerre froide à gauche américaine anti
communiste à cette époque de fait ils
font partie de ce libéralisme de guerre
froide l'histoire du néoconservatisme
commence réellement dans les années 60
sous les présidences de john fitzgerald
kennedy puis lyndon johnson
deux démocrates qui portent des projets
de société dans la continuité du new
deal
d'ailleurs avant de continuer il faut
dire quelques mots sur le new deal car
il s'agit d'un événement important qui a
donné naissance au clivage gauche droite
moderne aux états unis avant la crise de
le parti démocrate est un parti
centriste libéral au sens classique du
terme lorsque le démocrate franklin
roosevelt est élu président en 1932 il
met en place le new deal pour sortir le
pays de la crise il lance des grands
travaux et créer les assurances chômage
et retraite
le parti démocrate devient alors un
parti interventionniste contrairement à
l'idéal libéral classique
c'est avec le new deal que le terme
libéral commença dérivés aux états unis
pour devenir synonyme d'
interventionnisme étatique de programmes
sociaux d'état providence à l'américaine
et a désigné la gauche aujourd'hui
encore la volonté de prolonger les
politiques du new deal d'améliorer les
programmes sociaux ou au contraire de
les abroger marque l'opposition gauche
droite dans les années 60
kennedy et johnson porte donc des
projets sociaux dans la lignée du new
deal kennedy créer les community action
programme des sortes de plans d'action
social participatif impliquant
localement les populations pauvres
johnson lui améliore les protections
sociales en créant medicare et medicaid
et fait voter des lois abolissant la
discrimination raciale dans le sud étant
jeune universitaire ou membres de
cabinets ministériels les futurs
néoconservateurs participe à la mise en
place de ces mesures sociales d'abord
avec enthousiasme dans un esprit très
technocrates pour eux les experts armés
de leurs savoirs peuvent transformer la
société
mais très vite ils déchantent et
réaliste et tirent des banques
de leurs actions notamment à travers la
revue the public interest fondé par
daniel bell et irving kristol au fil d
analyse la revue mettra en avant un fait
gênant les programmes sociaux rate
souvent leurs objectifs
entraînant des effets pervers imprévus
comme l'accroissement de la dépendance
des populations pauvres aux subsides de
l'état sans pour autant les sortir de la
misère
cette conclusion sera à l'origine de la
frilosité futur des néoconservateurs
vis-à-vis de l'intervention étatique et
d'une particularité de ce courant à
savoir l'intérêt pour le poids de la
culture dans les déterminismes sociaux
si l'argent public ne suffit pas à
résorber la pauvreté c'est qu'une partie
du problème doit avoir une explication
hors du champ strictement économique le
rapport mené and de 1965 sur la pauvreté
des familles noires est assez
représentatif de cette façon de penser
ce rapport officiel explique la pauvreté
persistante des noirs à travers le
prisme culturel et menez and explique
qu'un des facteurs de maintien de la
pauvreté et la déliquescence des
familles noires où les familles
monoparentales sont sur représentés ce
qui entraîne des problèmes financiers
mais aussi éducatif tout reposant sur
les femmes
le rapport préconise de fournir des
formations et des emplois aux hommes
pour leur redonner leur dignité
ce qui leur permettra d'assumer leur
rôle de pater familias stabilisant ainsi
les familles et contribuant à faire
reculer les problèmes de la communauté
afro-américaine ses recommandations à la
fois conservatrice et social tranche
avec les méthodes préconisées à l'époque
à gauche où l'on préfère la
discrimination positive et mind et anne
fut accusé de racisme et de sexisme dans
un style beaucoup plus polémique
podhoretz lui écrire à mon problème
noire où il explique qu enfants vivant
dans un quartier pauvre de new york
les seuls qui était mal habillé mal
tenus par leurs parents qui jouait les
racailles étaient les enfants noirs
mettant ainsi brutalement en avant la
question de la culture des comportements
des moeurs dans le maintien de la
pauvreté une autre question
problématique est celle de la
discrimination positive et des quotas
qui voit le jour dans les années 60 les
néo conservateurs y sont farouchement
opposés nathan de glaeser justifie cette
opposition par le fait que la
discrimination positive ne fait
qu'accélérer l'ascension sociale de
personnes déjà dans une dynamique
positive et ne règle pas le problème de
la pauvreté de la grande majorité ces
quotas de plus créer du ressentiment
chez les pauvres non noire et va à
l'encontre de la logique citoyenne
aveugle aux origines de chacun également
un peu con
andres ce refus de la discrimination
positive en se rappelant de l'origine
familiale de nos néo conservateurs la
plupart d'entre eux sont issus de
l'immigration récente et doivent leur
ascension sociale à la méritocratie et
non à des quotas ethniques
quelque part ce qu'ils défendent c'est
l'american dream que eux mêmes ont vécu
et puis à cette déconvenue lié à
l'action politique démocrate a très vite
revenir sans ajouter une seconde les
années 50 et 60 sont marqués par
l'apparition d'une nouvelle gauche
socialement et culturellement différente
de celle des décennies précédentes et on
est alors en plein dans ce qu'on appelle
les radicales sixties de nouvelles
luttes et questions apparaissent hors du
champ économique mouvement anti-guerre
contre-culture libération sexuelle usage
des drogues radicalisation d'une partie
du mouvement noir etc
ces luttes sont portés en grande partie
par les milieux intellectuels et
étudiants
cette gauche d'un nouveau genre
différente de l'ancienne dans ses
revendications mais aussi dans sa
sociologie est appelé de façon parlante
nouvelle gauche les motifs de divorce
avec la gauche traditionnelle sont
nombreux la nouvelle gauche est plus
intéressé par les questions sociétales
que par les luttes sociales au nom de la
critique baigne dans une sorte de
relativisme moral complet et mais les
campus sans dessus dessous avec ses
mobilisation permanente
menant une chasse aux sorcières contre
tout ce qui n'est pas aussi radicale
qu'elle les néoconservateurs qui sont
souvent universitaires sont alors aux
premières loges et voient leurs
institutions se transformer en zone de
contestation de toutes les valeurs
américaines
l'ambiance sur les campus et délétère
par exemple en 1969 un groupe
d'étudiants noirs radicaux de
l'université de cornell occupe un
bâtiment armes à la main et ainsi
obtiennent la création d'un centre
d'études afro américaine autre exemple
en mai 1970 une série de manifestations
contre l'invasion du cambodge secoue
l'université de kent un bâtiment de la
réserve militaire étudiante est
incendiée et la garde nationale ouvre le
feu lors d'une manif bilan 4 morts et au
delà de l'agitation les néoconservateurs
perçoivent les revendications sociétales
comme du relativisme moral
or il ne supporte pas le relativisme
c'est l'une de leurs particularités de
leurs études sociales de leurs
réflexions
il tire la conclusion que toute société
a besoin de règles et d'institutions
sociales pour fonctionner régler valeurs
que le capitalisme qui n'est qu'un
système économique ne génère pas il faut
donc des cadres des institutions
sociales comme la famille ou la religion
pour porter ces valeurs
toute chose que la nouvelle gauche
voudrait voir disparaître au nom de
l'émancipation de l'individu
ils vont donc produire une analyse ou
plutôt une critique de la noue
gauche avec un ensemble de concepts qui
vise à la polémique pour eux cette
dérive de la gauche du social vers le
sociétal du progressisme libéral vers le
radicalisme est due aux nouvelles
classes intellectuels de gauche ce
qu'ils appellent la new classe terme
plus polémique que sociologique classe
qui paradoxalement critique le système
tout en vivant de ses subsides et qui
propage ce qu'ils appellent l'adversaire
et culture la culture contestataire une
espèce d'auto dénigrement permanent de
culture pénitentielle de culpabilisation
de la société américaine qui serait
l'unique origine de tous les maux de la
terre
à ces deux déconvenues va bientôt s'y
ajouter une troisième à la fin des
années 60 une partie de la nouvelle
gauche des radicalise entre au parti
démocrate dont elle va gauchir la ligne
et auquel elle va apporter ses intérêts
sociétaux ces nouveaux militants vont
remettre les primaires au goût du jour
pour désigner le candidat à la
présidentielle
alors qu'à l'époque on laisse plutôt les
cadres faire leur tambouille au passage
ils vont demander des quotas pour
représenter les minorités opprimées les
noirs les femmes et les jeunes
parmi les délégués élus résultats lors
des primaires de 1972 c'est le candidat
de l'ailé gauche du parti
george mcgovern qui l'emportent au grand
désespoir des néoconservateurs mcgovern
et isolationnistes et veut retirer les
troupes du vietnam
il veut renforcer les programmes sociaux
et la discrimination positive et même
créer un revenu universel
ce programme lui fait gagner la primaire
mais perdre la présidentielle face à
nick stone et c'est une véritable claque
17 grands électeurs pour mcgovern contre
521 pour nixon la ligne gauchistes ayant
effrayer les électeurs modérés
quelques jours après les élections
benoît den berg et peine campbell deux
dirigeants du parti socialiste américain
un petit parti associé aux démocrates
réagissent à la dérive gauchiste en
créant la cdm la coalition pour une
majorité démocrate
nos néo conservateurs vont les rejoindre
ainsi que de nouveaux arrivants comme
jane kirkpatrick politologue où le jeune
rosto juristes ainsi que des dirigeants
de l'aef lci au la grande centrale
syndicale américaine réformiste et
anticommuniste tout ce petit monde veut
combattre l'influencé de la nouvelle
gauche et défendre les orientations
classique du parti démocrate à savoir la
défense des classes populaires
l'alliance avec les syndicats et la
priorité donnée aux revendications
économiques la cdm de par ses objectifs
et sa composition est la seule
organisation 100% néoconservatrice de
notre histoire
elle va s'impliquer dans les commissions
de rénovation du parti organisée suite à
la catastrophe mcdo
elle va réussir à faire abandonner
l'idée de quotas parmi les délégués aux
primaires et défendra l'idée de délégués
nommés par l'appareil du parti pour
modérer ce élus par la base
indirectement la cdm est à l'origine des
supers délégués qui depuis leur création
ont effectivement contribué à empêcher
la victoire de tout candidat trop
radical bernie sanders étant le dernier
en date à en avoir fait les frais et
c'est ainsi qu'au cours des années 60
début 70
à force de débats avec la nouvelle
gauche d'articles de fond ou polémique
dans un public interest et commentary qu
un corps de doctrine plutôt qu'un esprit
prend forme fait de méfiance vis-à-vis
des grandes réformes sociales et des
nouvelles idées sociétal s'explique
pourquoi aussi entre 1965 et 1970
progressivement on commence à parler de
notre nébuleuse d'intellectuels comme
étant des néo conservateurs dans ces
années 60 début 70
ce conservatisme peut se résumer à
l'auto définition de daniel bell se
déclarant à la fois socialiste libéral
et conservateur selon les domaines
la droite verra d'un bon oeil ces
critiques venant de gauche et dès 1971
la national review les invitera à
rejoindre le camp républicain
mais reprenons notre histoire à partir
de 1973
les néo conservateurs vont changer de
centre d'intérêt vont délaisser la
politique intérieure et vont se
focaliser sur la menace soviétique
pourquoi se tournant vers
l'international d'abord il ya les deux
guerres israélo-arabes nombre de nos
démocrates conservateurs sont juifs
etienne à israël mais il ya aussi des
raisons moins sentimentale les pays
arabes sont des dictatures pro
soviétique alors qu israël est le seul
pays démocratique et de gauche de la
région
la stratégie politique américaine a
aussi joué nixon le président
républicain et son conseiller kissinger
met en place la politique de détente
visant à faire baisser la tension entre
les usa et l'urss
pour ce faire il utilise la technique du
linkage à savoir des négociations
permettant à chaque super puissance de
proposer une avancée dans un domaine en
échange d'une avancée dans un autre cela
a pour effet de faciliter et dépolitiser
les négociations
l'urss a besoin de blé et de technologie
et en échange peut céder du terrain dans
le domaine politique
cette stratégie scandalise les néo
conservateurs pour qui la lutte contre
le régime soviétique est aussi une lutte
morale avant
véritable combat contre un ennemi
civilisationnel il s'agit de défendre la
liberté et les droits de l'homme contre
l'oppression et la tyrannie
comme pour la politique intérieure il ne
supporte pas le relativisme et pour eux
les négociations avec l'urss ne peuvent
pas juste être une négociations de
marchands de tapis
ils vont donc s'employer art politiser
la question soviétique et à faire
échouer les négociations mais aussi à
muscler la politique militaire
américaine et vont devenir faucon aux
usa on distingue les partisans de la
guerre les faucons des pacifistes les
colombes et si jusqu'ici il n'était pas
favorable à l'engagement armé contre
l'urss il était contre la guerre au
vietnam
ils vont à partir des années 70
développer une vision belliqueuse et
devenir partisans de l'endiguement à
savoir l'utilisation de la force armée
pour empêcher des pays de basculer dans
le camp soviétique
plusieurs pôles vont apparaître dans ce
combat contre l'urss et à nos
intellectuels new yorkais vont venir
s'ajouter des politiciens de washington
et les jeunes membres de leur cabinet
d'abord il y à la cdm dont ce n'est pas
le but initial l axe son action autour
de la défense des droits de l'homme
bafoués en union soviétique et invite
nombre de dissidents à s'exprimer on
peut aussi compter sur commentary
toujours tenues parfois de rex la revue
publiera par exemple une série
d'articles écrits par pat monahan dans
lesquelles il pourfend l'équivalence
morale usa urss série d'articles qui
sera remarquée par kissinger
il faudra à leurs auteurs d'être nommé
ambassadeur des usa aux nations unies en
1975 - yann ne restera en poste qu'un an
mais s'attirera la sympathie de
l'opinion publique américaine en
bataillant contre la résolution 3379 de
l'onu portés par l'urss et les pays
arabes
assimilant le sionisme un racisme de
nouveaux venus se joignent aussi à
l'histoire du néoconservatisme à cette
époque à savoir le sénateur démocrate
chris coons jackson et ses jeunes
conseillers entre autres richard pearl
et paul wolfowitz scouts jackson
s'emploiera à saboter la stratégie du
linkage en obligeant le gouvernement
lors des négociations a systématiquement
demander la possibilité pour les juifs
soviétiques d'immigrer en israël mettant
ainsi l'urss dans l'embarras vis à vis
de ses alliés arabes lui aussi
s'implique dans la défense des droits de
l'homme et par exemple il participera à
la médiatisation de la venue de
soljénitsyne aux états unis
à côté de la repolitisation du conflit
les néoconservateurs pousse aussi à la
surenchère militaire à l'époque la
doctrine militaire amérique
n est simple il s'agit de la destruction
mutuelle chacun sarm le plus possible en
tête nucléaire pour détruire l'autre
s'il est envahie ou attaquer pour les
néo conservateurs
cette stratégie doit être abandonnée au
profit d'une logique de supériorité
technologique garantissant non pas
l'anéantissement mutuelle mais la survie
des usa d'où leur opposition aux
négociations de désarmement
cette question militaire sera porté par
le cpdh et le comité pour le danger
présent un groupe trans partisan rempli
de néoconservateurs de la cdm est créé
par l'un d'entre eux genro stop
ce comité produira des rapports et
mènera des campagnes vers l'opinion
publique
très alarmiste sur le niveau d'armement
de l'urss au niveau de la politique
intérieure lors des primaires de 1976
les néo conservateurs misent tout sur
scoop jackson mais manque de chance
c'est un quasi inconnu
jimmy carter qui est désigné candidat et
qui gagnera la présidentielle la même
année
mian devient sénateur de new york il
détiendra ce siège jusqu'en 2000 date à
laquelle une certaine hillary clinton
lui succédera le président carter lui
tentera de se concilier les néo
conservateurs mais sans succès sa
politique vis-à-vis de l'urss est jugée
trop conciliante
d'autant que la fin des années 70
marquent un regain d'activité soviétique
et anti américaine il y a par exemple
l'expédition cubaine en angola
l'invasion de l'afghanistan par l'urss
mais aussi la révolution iranienne et
tout cela conforte nos faucon dans leur
ligne dure et les éloignent des
positions démocrates classique et ce au
point que la présidentielle de 1981 va
être un véritable cas de conscience
le candidat démocrate n'est autre que le
président carter qui a fortement déçu
nos néo conservateurs et pour la
première fois la question se pose
faut-il soutenir le candidat démocrate
ou bien le candidat républicain qui
n'est autre que ronald reagan
un ancien libéral de guerre froide est
passé à droite réputée pour son
anticommunisme nombre de néo
conservateurs vont donc soutenir
officieusement le candidat républicain
et le comité pour les dangers présents
lui ira même jusqu à le soutenir
officiellement mais bon il faut aussi
dire que régalant les membres à partir
de ce moment là au contact du pouvoir
républicain est désormais tourné quasi
exclusivement vers la question
internationale
le basculement à droite d'une partie du
néoconservatisme commence reagan et élus
et de nombreux néo conservateur surtout
les plus jeunes arrivés dans les années
70 entre dans son administration
parmi les plus importants eugène rostock
dirigera l'agencé du contrôle de
l'armement et jeane kirkpatrick sera
nommée ambassadrice à l'onu
il faut dire qu'elle a été remarquée de
1979 par reagan après un article publié
dans commentary dans lequel elle expose
sa vision internationale fait
d'anticommunisme viscéral de quoi plaire
à reagan qui lui appelle l'urss l'empiré
du mal la rencontre
kirkpatrick reagan donnera naissance à
une politique internationale musclées
faites de soutien aux guérillas
anticommuniste les néoconservateurs
s'installe aussi dans les think tanks
conservateurs comme l'american
enterprise institute qui accueille
nombreux d'entre eux certains vont
s'intéresser à la religion comme facteur
morale pour la société capitaliste et
vont se rapprocher des sphères
évangélique républicaine allant jusqu'à
fonder un think tank oecuménique
l'institut sur la démocratie et la
religion et puis la politique interne du
parti démocrate est d'aussi ainsi jane
park patrick lassé de l' influence de la
nouvelle gauche adhérera au parti
républicain en 1985 dans cette période
la stratégie internationale est source
de conflits entre néoconservateurs un
clivage en partie générationnel
apparaissant les plus âgés comme
christoph glaser ou kirkpatrick son
faucon mais reste mesuré dans leur
interventionnisme
il ne faut pas laisser des pays basculer
dans le camp soviétique mais en restant
dans la realpolitik
le but est surtout de protéger les états
unis les plus jeunes eux comme wolf aux
beats sont partisans d'une véritable
croisade pour la démocratie
forgeant une vision de la politique
internationale qui aura la vie dure les
décennies suivantes
et si tout va pour le mieux pour les
néoconservateurs rallier à
l'administration reagan
ceux qui sont restés à gauche par contre
[ __ ] dans la semoule car pendant tout
ce temps la cdl est restée active pour
tenter de réorienter le parti démocrate
vers le centre mais sans succès
les candidats vainqueur des primaires
malgré la modification du mode de
désignation sont issus ou influencé par
l'ailé gauche du parti et les score
calamiteux aux présidentielles se
succèdent invariablement néanmoins le
parti revient tout de même
progressivement à des positions plus
modérées et ce grâce à l'action des
démocrates du sud et nouveaux démocrates
qui crée le dlc le democratic leadership
council bill clinton
l'un de ces nouveaux démocrates gagnera
la primaire et la présidentielle de 1992
le dlc un comité d'élus aura donc réussi
en quelques années
là où la cdm un comité d'intellectuels a
échoué pendant 20 ans pendant ces années
80 le néo conservatisme
va aussi se scléroser restant figé dans
la guerre froide des années 70 et sera
incapable d'actualiser son logiciel au
point de croire que les soviétiques
peuvent encore gagner la guerre froide
alors même que le bloc de l'est est à
deux doigts de s'effondrer du coup la
chute surprise de l'urss les laisse à
gare sans ennemi identifiés et sans
réelle raison d'être
les néo conservateurs vont alors tenter
de savoir de quoi l'avenir peut être
fait sans le bloc de l'est
francis fukuyama écrira un livre devenu
célèbre annonçant la fin de l'histoire
pour lui après la chute de l'urss
il n'y aura plus de conflit samuel
huntington dans son choc des
civilisations prophétise rat un futur
dans lequel l'affrontement ne se fera
plus en fonction de grandes idéologies
mais en fonction de blog culturel
d'autres tirent la conclusion que leur
courant de pensée n'a plus lieu d'être
comme norman podhoretz qui se définit
désormais comme étant seulement
conservateur d'autres vont faire leur
retour au parti démocrate
l'élection de bill clinton les ayant
rassuré sur l'évolution du parti fidèles
à leur vision interventionniste ils
encourageront le président s'engager
dans la guerre de bosnie et puis tous
les néo conservateurs n'ont pas suivi
notre histoire jusqu'au bout daniel bell
qui a toujours été le plus à gauche a
laissé le mouvement au milieu des années
70 et marine et anne au milieu des
années 80 également après des doutes
initiaux face au monde sans urss le
néoconservatisme de droite va trouver un
nouveau souffle une nouvelle génération
va apparaître au cours des années 90 il
s'agit en partie d'une succession
familiale puisqu'on y retrouve william
kristol le fils divine et john podhoretz
le fils de norman qui reprend commentary
eux sont des conservateurs natif ayant
les mêmes préoccupations internationales
que les néoconservateurs notamment la
volonté d'exporter la démocratie et la
recherche d'une suprématie militaire
américaine
et puis d'anciens jeunes issus de la
sphère scoop jackson se retrouveront
dans l'administration bush et seront à
l'origine de sa vision internationale
après le 11 septembre fait
d'exportations volontariste de la
démocratie parmi eux on peut citer
richard pearl et surtout paul wolfowitz
bras droit de donald rumsfeld
à la défense on en retrouve aussi dans
l'administration trump notamment elliott
abrams qui est entre autres le gendre de
norman podhoretz et notre histoire est
maintenant terminée s'il vous a
intéressé n'hésitez pas à partager cette
vidéo
et si vous voulez en savoir plus sur le
sujet je vous invite à lire l'histoire
du néoconservatisme aux états unis de
justin vaïsse un ouvrage issu d'un
travail de thèse en histoire ouvrage
extrêmement complet qui a même été
traduit en anglais et il faut dire ce
qui est
cette vidéo lui dois énormément pour le
reste je vous donne rendez-vous dans la
prochaine vidéo dans laquelle on verra
comment cette histoire américaine peut
nous aider à comprendre les dynamiques
en cours au sein de la gauche française
d'ici là portez vous bien et à la
prochaine
[Musique]